I'm Mitch Stansby. I'm a scout master for True Floor Floor in Oran Beach, Florida.
This edition of Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Clark, you're doing a great job. Thank you for all you do for scouting.
And now to you. Scout Master
School's out. It's the end of June, the beginning of July
And of course we all know what that means. Scout Summer Camp is coming right.
We're headed off in a couple of weeks. I know some of you are getting ready to go
or maybe have come back and have already been.
I have this report from my meeting with the camp counselors at our camp.
The Orienteering Counselor- I recommend him highly- has a magnetic personality,
is a little overbearing at times and he gets needled about that,
but he on balance does a pretty good job.
The pioneering counselors were playing the best music.
They had all the right chords
Over. in the nature department geology merit badge was totally rocking.
but the bird study counselor seemed a little experienced
because I thought he was just winging it at times.
I got along with most of the counselors I met.
I was kind of repelled by the climbing instructor
Down at the pool. Aquatics was going swimmingly.
One of the new counselors was a little dippy.
I think he was just a little wet behind the ears
and he tried to cash a buddy check at the trading post.
And speaking of the trading post, they were doing a fine job.
There was one afternoon where they got a little behind in their work
because one of them backed into the slushy machine.
I did visit the health lodge.
The first aid instructor was pretty competent
but he couldn't really wrap his head around bandaging.
And down in the handicraft department,
scouts working on metal work merit badge. they were forging ahead
And basketry merit badge was going okay
but it was kind of hampered because the counselor was a slow reader.
So there's your report from summer camp.
I hope that helps.
Oh, my goodness.
Well, this is podcast number 228..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag and see what's happening.
Frank Maynard commented on last week's podcast,
especially about one of the email questions
where we were talking about council mergers.
Frank said we've gone through two mergers
in our area over the last few years.
Our local council merged with another council
And then, a couple of years later,
all the councils in Michigan merged together
and became one large coordinating council.
This model may spread around the country
and may auger many more mergers to come.
What happened here is that the scouting experience
at the unit level seemed to change very little.
Merging councils can be a messy affair,
but if adults take a positive attitude
and find ways to ensure the scouting experience
is improved for the youth we serve,
which is really the intention of mergers anyway- right,
The merger of councils can be done successfully
with many benefits
And Frank also lent this bit of advice
when we were advising a den leader
about getting their den up to speed in leadership.
Frank reminds us of the position
in a Weevillows den, called a denner,
which is similar to a patrol leader,
And it's a good way to introduce boys to the concept
of leadership and service to their fellow scouts.
Thanks, Frank, for that advice and those points
Always appreciated.
We also heard from Merrick Fosenbeck
from Troop 581 in Lehigh Utah
And he said: all right, Clark, the geek in me,
Just had to figure this one out
And what he was trying to figure out.
a couple of podcasts ago
somebody was happy to hear the podcast number
because it corresponded with their unit number
And I kind of quipped that we could dedicate
each podcast to the unit
that corresponded with the podcast number.
Then I heard from somebody from Troop 918
who wondered how long it would take
before I got the podcast number 918..
And Merrick was kind enough to figure it out.
He says if you keep doing the podcast
and if you keep the schedule
of releasing a new podcast on Monday each week,
then Troop 918 will have the chance
to be mentioned in podcast 918
on Monday September 20th 2027..
So they've got a long time to wait.
Oh my
Well, thank you, Merrick, for doing that. I think
Van Donnelly got in touch about our talk
about outdoor leadership.
He said two popular ideas in the tech
and the startup worlds are:
failing fast and minimum viable project.
I believe both of these can be applied to scouting.
We don't expect scouts to start learning
how to build a fire with a big, giant, elaborate fire.
We want them to concentrate on the basics
of gathering what they need to build the fire.
The minimum viable project-
As fun as fire building- is the organizational skills
to put everything together and get the fire lit.
and burning doesn't come easy to scouts.
We want them to fail fast
and learn what they've done
and try again to their success.
Again, I agree:
Failing fast and the minimum viable project
is a good concept for scouts,
because we want them in that loop as quickly as possible.
We don't need to over explain,
We don't need to over instruct.
Let them get at it, That's the whole thing.
Let them be active, Let them fail fast,
Let them produce, you know,
kind of a minimal product to begin with,
And then they have a basis of experience
upon which to learn the more advanced things. right,
George Zach got in touch and said
thanks for the ongoing delivery of the great podcast.
It makes me think about how I approach scouting.
I've been listening for about six months now.
Even when my kind of knee jerk reaction
has not been in complete agreement with you,
I can see the way you came to the point
and the wisdom in it.
I was kind of surprised to disagree with you
on your recent thoughts on outdoor leadership.
I think you mixed two things in this conversation
and didn't differentiate between leadership
skills or the tools that we use
and the different environments.
Leadership skills apply across environments
and they're pretty much the same
And, George, I agree with you.
We really end up not disagreeing.
It just may be that I inartfully expressed myself
when I was talking about this.
Yes, leadership skills are the same,
The settings are different, but the skills are the same.
And George ended his message by saying:
anyway, thanks in any case for leading me to think about this,
George, I appreciate that That's what we need to do.
I think that that's probably the most useful thing I can do
is get everybody thinking.
I might not be able to express myself
in the best way possible sometimes,
And sometimes what I say may seem a little confusing
or conflicting, but I think the goal in the end
is to get everybody thinking right,
Because once we think, hopefully that leads us
to better answers and makes us better scouters.
And finally, from the mailbag: this week,
in recursive replies,
both of these scouters got in touch
after they were mentioned in the previous podcast:
Rob Kerrigan, to say thanks for the shout out.
I felt like I was in a speech by the president.
That's Rob Kerrigan up there in Maine.
Hello, Rob, Now you've been mentioned again.
And Dave Klein, who said woo-hoo,
Love being mentioned in the mailbag.
So there's your recursive replies for this week.
This week on Baden Powell's blog,
the title of the post was Education.
You want to make sure to check that out.
Every week on a Sunday
I'll post a bit of Baden Powell's writing
just to tie us to our past.
Just about everything that he had to say
still works now-
All the principles and the methods
on which he founded Scouting.
They're still perfectly applicable 100 years later.
The quiz this week was: do you know your maps?
And the tough ones seem to be rapids and waterfalls.
So pay attention to those answers very closely, okay,
And see if you can figure those out.
Shared a PDF version and a print version
of a patrol log book that you may find useful.
We also reported on something that was in the national news:
Scouts who survived a mishap while on a trip
in the boundary canoe waters.
Do be sure to check that one out.
I should go on to say-
and I think it's pretty clear in the post-
that the reason I wanted to talk about that
was not to sensationalize
or really even try to definitively analyze a mishap
based only on news reporting,
because I don't think that's a totally responsible way
to respond to something like this.
But to give you the story to work with
is something to think about,
because when we are familiar with the way
that these things unfold,
it helps us to avoid them in the future.
I think that the good message to come from that story
was that this scouting safety net-
the things that we drill our scouts in
and we drill ourselves in-
really, really works,
because everybody got to walk away
from that particular incident
And early last week
we had a post about hitting the wall,
which was talking about something that happens,
at least in my experience,
to almost every youth leader I've ever worked with.
So you want to check out that post
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
So a couple of quick things before we get going.
A couple of thousand of you used the Scoutmaster CG app.
It's a great way to keep the resources we created
your fingertips right there on your mobile device,
And you can get the app on iTunes
for your Android devices
or at Google Play for your iPhones and iPads.
A growing number of generous scouts
have become backers for ScoutmasterCGcom.
I have some premiums to offer to those of you
who are willing to lend some financial support
to the blog and the podcast.
If you've gotten something out of these things,
well, you can return the favor
and make it possible for me to create and publish these
by becoming a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
And I want to make sure to recognize Heather Culliton,
who signed up to be a backer this past week.
Thank you very much, Heather.
It really means a great deal.
So this week's podcast is a little bit different.
I'm going to finish up with a Scoutmasters Minute.
before I get there, though,
I want to talk to parents about Scoutcamp-
Not necessarily talking to Scouters,
but just to parents of Scouts,
with some thoughts about preparing themselves
and their Scouts for camp this summer
and what really happens at camp,
And that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
so let's get started, shall we
Well? Camp Granada. I think you know,
if you're a certain age you remember that song right.
But anyway, on one Sunday afternoon soon
I'll be standing in our campsite at our Scout camp
as our Scouts begin to arrive for their week at summer camp.
Our camp is about a half hour drive away.
Scouts arrive at camp for the week individually.
Their parents bring them down.
We usually walk down to the campsite with them
And I'll be watching as the senior patrol leader
and the older Scouts sort things out
and help the Scouts find their tents
and get things moving.
And it's interesting because parents who are veterans of this,
whose boys have been to camp several times,
they spend a very short amount of time in the campsite.
They usually get down there.
They kind of unload the Scout,
They say goodbye and they head back up and head home.
Parents of Scouts who are there for their first year
perhaps will spend a little bit more time,
because this may be the first time
that their son is going to be away from them
for that long a period of time.
Their son is going to be out of their orbit,
And you know what It's. a little worrisome, isn't it?
And I've watched this with parents for 30 years now,
And so if you're one of those parents,
I want to speak to you a little bit
about what I see from my side
and what happens during the week of summer camp.
I will tell you, without a doubt,
that your son is going to come home from summer camp
more capable and mature than he was
when you waved goodbye to him,
Outside of the normal support structure
of his parents and his family
and away from all of those solitary distractions
that bother us in one way or another.
He's away from the internet.
He's away from his computer games,
He's away from the television set.
He's got to take care of himself
and cooperate with his peers.
He's got to interact with people.
He does all this in a very supportive environment
that permits him to try things out
and maybe get them wrong,
without compromising his safety.
But he's going to be challenged
to expand his abilities
to accept and offer help
and to function cooperatively in everyday tasks.
If you think about it,
what your scout does at camp
is pretty amazing,
And he does 99% of this
without the mediation
of an adult reminding him to do so.
He is challenged to be responsible
not only for himself
but for his fellow scouts.
So he's going to get up in the morning on schedule.
He's going to be sharing a tent
with another scout
and they're going to need to keep that tent
reasonably neat and clean.
He's going to share chores with his fellow scouts
to maintain the campsite,
Depending on where he goes to camp.
at some scout camps
they serve meals in the campsite.
At some there's a dining hall
or has a dining hall,
And he's going to share three meals a day,
served basically family style
meals.
It's been some years since we had a scout in our house,
but I know that
when he was in middle school and high school
at least, we felt pretty fortunate
to have two or three meals a week
where we were all sitting at the same table.
But this is going to happen: three meals a day
for every day that he's at camp-
And you know what Grace is going to be said.
he's going to have his opportunity
to serve as a waiter for his table
and serving and cleaning up after meals.
He's going to manage and budget
given him for camp.
He's going to set and follow a schedule
of activities according to his interests.
He's going to be responsible
to find his way to and from those activities
and manage his time.
He's going to build character
and values by attending campfires
and ceremonies
and reflecting on those activities.
He's going to find himself complimented
many times by the older scouts
that are charged with his well-being.
His opinions are actually going to be
heard, and heard by other scouts and adults.
He's going to have the opportunity
to take on real responsibility
at times
and to be the leader of other scouts.
He's going to make new friends.
He's going to strengthen his existing friendships.
He's going to learn new skills.
He's going to try something
he's probably never tried before.
He's going to become more aware
of the natural environment that we live in.
He's going to challenge
his critical thinking skills.
He's going to put what he learns
into action. He's going to work with others
to establish and achieve goals.
He's going to be challenged to
apply himself to contribute
to achieving those goals.
He's going to trade all of those
solitary pursuits like TV and video games
and all of that
for actual social interaction.
He's going to have to find
a healthy resolution to conflicts
and he's going to benefit from
a tremendous positive peer pressure.
following the good example
of older scouts and counselors.
Now, summer camp
for a young scout
is going to be challenging,
but it's also an adventure
that's full of possibilities.
It's an opportunity for parents
to let him go a little,
Let him stand on his own two feet,
and when you do that,
that's an expression of confidence and trust
in his abilities
and it's really a test of your parenting.
and parents,
I find, are usually
a little less prepared
for summer camp than their sons
are. We will spend a lot of time
working with them to make sure that
they're ready. There is gear and clothing
and things like that to gather.
We may not appreciate
what it's going to be like at home
when our boy is off to summer camp.
It may be an uncomfortable
feeling turning over full
time care to
others that you maybe just have gotten
to know. Perhaps you're going to worry
about the kind of food that they're going to serve,
who's going to be looking after
your daily concerns, like clean clothes
and taking a shower,
and how the older scouts are going to treat him-
and that's a worry for every parent.
is he going to be teased?
are they going to be tough and mean to him?
and we're going to be worried if.
what? if he doesn't like
being at camp. Is he going to be able to call
home? or can we call
him and check in with him?
and all of these questions cause us a little bit of anxiety,
and you know what
a lot of times
we parents have a harder time
with the experience of sending
our sons off to scout camp
than they ever will- at camp,
I mean.
and that first letter home, if we even get
one, can sound kind of miserable
and we try to read between the lines
and, yeah, it can be
a distressing time for us
as parents. so I want to help
you prepare yourself for
this experience. if this is the
first time you're going to be separated from
your child for this
length of time, it's a new challenge
and, even though many others have gone
through it before, it's something
that's new to you, and the first
step is really acknowledging
that this is possibly
possibly going to cause you some
distress, no matter how much
I talk about it, no matter
how many other parents have been through it.
this challenge of being separated
from your child for this length of time
could be new to you,
but you know what. a lot of us
have gone through it before and
we know that it gets better. so don't worry
if you feel distressed or anxious,
it's pretty normal. it's a pretty
normal reaction, but it's temporary
and you're going to get over it
and you're going to feel better. now I will tell
you that most younger scouts
are going to encounter
some amount of homesickness.
they're going to have some ups
and downs because if camp
is going to reap the benefits that
we want from it, it's going to be challenging
for them. they're not going to be
abjectly miserable,
but they're going to find things
challenging and all of this
is really a part
of a healthy process of growing up
that scouts are going to encounter
one way or another
at one time or another.
if they're 11 or 12 years old
and they're off for a week at summer camp
without you, they're going to
encounter some of the same challenges
that are going to happen
when, after they've graduated high school,
which I know seems an impossibly
distant thing in the future,
but I can tell you it's right around the corner.
after they've graduated high school
and they've gone off to college,
they're going to be encountering the same things that they
encountered at camp, maybe on a bigger scale
and for a longer period of separation
from home. so getting
over that now, dealing
with it now, is a very
good thing for them to be able to do.
a couple of ways we can prepare ourselves
for this time that our
children are away at camp
is to think positively.
I know that sounds very trite,
doesn't it? but scouts
typically thrive
at summer camp and they come home happy.
and when you're talking to
your scout about camp,
instead of discussing your worries
and how much you're going to miss them,
talk about all
of the great things that are going to happen at camp
and the great new experiences they're going to have.
keep everything on a positive level-
and of course
you're going to miss them.
of course it's going to be difficult for you,
but one of the ways that you
can kind of help your scout
avoid feeling really homesick
for camp when you're discussing it with your scout,
stay positive
for a long time scout master.
I am always ready
to answer questions about summer camp
and there aren't any silly questions.
really, it's always better
to ask than to worry,
and a lot of parents worry
about things that
they may consider silly.
well, what if he doesn't like the food?
what if he runs out of clean clothes?
what if he runs out of money?
what if he really doesn't like it? there
is there a way that he can call us,
but we have to come and pick him up.
you know, ask those questions,
and there may be a lot of questions
that are just kind of specific
to a given summer camp
or given scout troop that I won't
have the answers to here.
so ask the people who are going to camp
with them. there really aren't any silly questions
and it's always better
to ask than to worry about the answers.
right now I will tell you.
one of the things you're going to want to understand
is how you'll be
able to communicate with your scout
while he's at camp,
and most of the time this is going to be
pretty minimal communication.
before the advent of cell phones
and things like that, it was almost exclusively
one way communication,
when the scout
was encouraged or compelled
to send a letter or a postcard
home. usually you can mail
a letter or a card for them at camp.
I know at our camp you can
email messages to scouts
that could be helpful for you
talking to them on the phone.
well, you know what it all depends.
I don't have a
blanket policy and I don't have
blanket advice for how to
manage that yourself.
I will say that generally
it's a better idea
to minimize those types of communications.
I will address home sickness
and scouts by making sure
that they can contact home
and talk to home,
and in my experience that actually
helps. over time
we got to remember that every experience
and every set of challenges is an individual one.
so the way that these communications
are going to work
and exactly what you'll be able to do
and what you won't be able to do
is something that you should ask questions about,
and you should also prepare your scout for that.
unless your
summer camp is very close by,
like ours is,
it may not be very likely that you're going to get a chance
to visit camp. if you do get a chance
to visit, there are going to be some rules
associated with that visit
and it's something that you want to familiarize
yourself with at our particular
camp on a Saturday, when parents
can visit, we can have several hundred
extra people in camp and you can imagine
that that can be a little stressful
for the camp staff and even for the adults
that are down with a scout troop.
so think very carefully
about the impact your visits going to have
and be respectful of the rules
and the common practices around that.
and finally, to get ready
to send your son off to camp,
think about planning something special for yourself.
you're having a little mini vacation
from being a parent
for a few days.
plan something interesting or special
that you couldn't otherwise do,
and make that happen while they're away at camp.
as with most other things in life,
this whole experience of being a parent
and sending your scout off to camp
really has a lot to do with
the way that you've prepared yourself,
the way that you've prepared your scout
and the attitude with which
you approach the entire thing.
there's going to be challenging times, for certain.
there's going to be challenging times for your
scout at camp.
there's going to be challenging times for you at home.
but I would have to say that,
based on my experience over 30 years
of doing this,
when you meet these challenges with a positive attitude,
both
yourself at home as a parent
going through this experience
and your scout at camp going through this experience.
you're both going to benefit from it.
the ninth point of the scout law:
quick, quick,
thrifty.
I have a fondness for words-
I really do- especially uncommon or obscure words
that have been around for a long time.
I find that words like this
creep into my conversation
very often
and when I talk like this
around my scouts
I usually get a confused look from the younger scouts
and the older scouts kind of glance at each other
as if to say there he goes again,
another one of those $9 college words
that nobody knows what it means.
but anyway,
thrifty is one of those
great old words,
a word you don't hear every day,
and I get a kick out of talking to scouts
in a scout masters conference
and asking them what they think thrifty means.
it's kind of like art link letters.
the things kids say or whatever that show was.
their answers are all
over the map and sometimes they're a little entertaining.
but understand
the fact that we use the word
thrifty in the scout law.
it would be a great opportunity to be able to discuss
the concepts behind it
with scouts,
because it's not a very common word.
now, I'm not suggesting that we ever dump
good old thrifty for something new
or something updated.
I think we need to keep thrifty around,
like we need to keep old men like me around,
because we're quirky and entertaining.
if you want to help scouts understand
thrifty,
then ask them what it means to be resourceful.
resourceful is not exactly a synonym,
but it's pretty close, isn't it?
in the handbook, the ninth point of the scout law
is explained this way:
a scout works to pay his own way
and to help others,
he saves for the future,
he protects and conserves natural resources
and he uses his time
and property wisely.
now we know the scout law isn't just for
scouts, it's there for us too.
so how, in our role as
scouts, are we thrifty
or resourceful?
I do that question in many ways, to be sure,
but I'm thinking about a certain
aspect of resourcefulness,
a daily opportunity for our scouts
to gain a useful life skill.
and to illustrate that,
I'm reminded of a cold, wet,
long November night
guiding a youth group over Indian Pass
in New York's Adirondack
Park right there in the high peaks region.
it was not my favorite trip ever,
but it was pretty memorable
as we headed over Indian Pass.
it was November, it was cold,
it started to sleet and to snow
and all but one of our
flashlights gave out.
so the only way to make progress
on this rocky, steep trail
was to light the trail ahead.
I had the only working light
and so
I would go up ahead of the group
and I would shine that light on the trail
and they would hike the twenty yards
or so up until they caught up with me,
and then I would go forward again
and they would catch up.
and so we kind of leapfrogged our way
over several miles of really tough terrain
in a slow,
steady slog well into
the early morning hours
before we got to our campsite.
our role in scouting
is similar: we illuminate the trail ahead
and we wait for the scouts to kind of catch up
with us and then we illuminate some more of the trail.
and the way that we do this
is by being resourceful
and thrifty with our words,
by asking good
questions,
because we want scouts
to learn to be resourceful
and thrifty themselves,
to find things out for themselves.
so asking a
well formed question opens
the doors of opportunity to them.
we tap the resourcefulness
of our scouts and appeal
to their sense of curiosity,
we get them up and active,
we ignite a flame of inquiry
when we are thrifty
with our words
and we're resourceful by asking them questions.
and where are the answers to those questions?
a lot of them end up being
within ourselves,
some are beyond ourselves,
but a lot of them cause us to look deep
into ourselves
and when we do that
we learn more about ourselves.
and when we do that in a positive environment,
we develop the character that is
the aim of scouting.
now, it is thrifty, but so are scouts.
be thrifty,
be resourceful
and light the way forward for your scouts
by asking good questions.
well, thank you for listening to this
228th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch.
read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
now. while you're there, you can subscribe
and join thousands who receive
the scoutmaster blog by email.
you can get the scoutmastercg app
on google play or at the itunes app store.
keep all of the resources that
we create right there at your fingertips
on your mobile device.
you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast
panorama of social media
outlets.
that's right. join 6000 folks
who like scoutmaster blog on facebook.
tweet along with the chorus
of over a thousand tweeters on twitter
and pin the poultry to news pictures
proffered publicly,
with 1600 other prolific
pinners on pinterest.
watch us, if you dare, at scoutmastercg
on youtube
and join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive scoutmastercg circle
on google plus.
now listen, bunkie.
if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you bitter,
if you have no interest in pinterest,
if you don't put the? u in youtube,
you'll miss when it comes to google plus.
does all this seem to take the
zip out of jet setting,
bunkie?
that's alright. zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
yeah, you can email me, clarkgreen.
your comments, questions and wild ideas
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
c, l, a,
r, k, e
at
scoutmastercgcom.
would it shock you to learn that the
scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
or any other scouting organization for that matter,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
doesn't amaze me. i'm pretty sure they have
much better things to do.
it's just me actually talking
into a microphone, trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun
here and there. and speaking of a little bit
of fun here and there, here's our founder,
Robert Baden Powell. sir robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
oh, i thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.